I mean is there a danger that companies
are going to repackage their existing
training programs to disguise this
apprenticeship levy I mean is it
actually going to make a difference yes
absolutely
so you you mention any introduction that
it was effectively just another tax and
it really just is so it will raise an
additional additional 2.8 billion by
2020 and the government's only gonna
spend about six hundred fourteen million
of that on new apprenticeships where's
where does the rest of their and
effectively just supports the rest of
the public finances right do you share
that assessment I would obviously defer
to Luke in terms of the numbers involved
but I think in order for it to be an
effective policy change there needs to
be a difference in terms of attitudes by
employers and society generally about
the apprenticeships and where they fit
in the modern workplace I mean companies
can claw back the cost of this but they
it's a bit of a legal and bureaucratic
minefield absolutely and that's probably
how they get to keep some of the money
that the leaks referred to I mean they
do get a 15,000 pound allowance that
gets offset against their levy there are
co-investment models where effectively
they pay 10% the government pays 90% but
it's very bureaucratic and I think where
you have organizations and sectors which
already pay and they're beat such as
engineering and construction they're
going to be paying this twice there's
much evidence of investing in
apprenticeships actually generates much
of an economic return and so if we look
at the apprenticeships that happened
during the 1990s and 2000s most of those
generated relatively good returns for
those who went through them and whether
they'll generate the same returns that
people doing lots of the new
apprenticeships I don't know because the
apprenticeships at the end of in the
whole series of industries they haven't
really been tried out before and they're
being developed at great speed to meet a
target have three million new
apprenticeships by 2020 and as Suzanne
says it sounds like we're almost gonna
have to rethink what kind of industries
are suitable for having the French
absolutely I think it meant there may
well be a very good case of having your
apprenticeships in new industries to
give young people more skills but
whether they actually we don't at such a
fast pace that's happening in the moment
I think that's a bit dangerous so what
are you hearing I mean have you spoken
much to individual companies about this
being a stealth tax and what does the
gut I mean the government obviously
watches what the IFS says like a halt
coming
what's been their reaction when you've
put these kind of ideas out there so I
haven't really heard any alternative
views about whether this is just an
increase in taxation it seems to be
straightforward when you look at the
government figures but I think there is
a view that perhaps this new system
might make them say this is their money
and want to exploit it as much as
possible so that might be something that
happens quite I mean what do you think
about the firm's position are you
getting calls from clients about this
are they anxious about it I mean it was
interesting I know some of the employees
organizations say they're not even aware
that their members may have to pay some
of these levies I think yeah I mean I
think such the challenge is really
looking at how to make use of the money
that's paid into this and I think it
means that you know employers are going
to need to sit down with their internal
teams work out what needs to be paid
through the payroll system and work out
how to make it work for them and I think
for larger employers they will most
definitely be subsidizing government
policy is there any way that firms can
avoid this I mean clearly it depends on
their turnover to an extent yeah I mean
I think you know it depends on their pay
bill I think one of the big challenges
about it is if they're in a group
structure and they're connected to other
companies they each of those separate
entities pay the levy but only one of
them can take the allowance so there is
some strategy that I think will need to
be worked through about how to make it
work for each of these companies and
what about the apprentices themselves
that are being taken on here where do we
think they're going to come from it's
quite hard to say at this point I mean
this is very much a new policy it's
going to apply to
we're told 29 different industries and
there are 1,200 Trailblazer
employers who are putting these
standards together and I think it's
going to be a question of looking at how
this works out in practice what those
standards are and what the take-up is do
you think Luke the government consulted
with employers enough I mean you've
called it a stealth taxi I did did they
talk to employees sufficiently I think
one of the great problems of vocational
education in this country is that
employers haven't really had much of a
stake or role in the development of
standards and one thing the governor has
been trying to do is get employers more
involved and this is
a financial incentive to trying get them
more involved whether they're world or
not I don't know but you asked about
what who these apprentices are going to
be and one thing we do know is that most
of the new apprentices to date haven't
been young people they've been people
aged over 25 like all of the growth has
been amended people aged over 25 all
right so not that not the sort of
traditional idea that we have of a
school leaver know it's changed quite a
lot over time so it's they're mostly
people aged over 25 they're in Business
Administration retail manufacturing
they're kind of in industries you
wouldn't necessarily expect them to be
in interesting now Suzanne what about
this gender paid reporting a yeah is the
government going to beat up on companies
that don't comply with the rules here
whether you would classify it as the
government's beating up on companies is
is probably a personal view but
essentially this is information that's
going to need to be disclosed publicly
on the website it's going to need to be
uploaded to the government and the
government has said that there could be
league tables and so it's certainly
going to get a lot of sort of public
coverage all right okay
Suzanne Horne Luke CBSA thanks both for
joining me